[Music]
in gaming coach news hey all gaming
culture submitted by I need to stop
playing for tonight man I didn't even
start that's how out of the loop I am
sometimes I feel like so [ __ ] dumb
and old 24:9 is one of those times that
I'm not playing oh I see because I'm
it's like I feel like I should we never
know coming out of Josie I don't know
what you're talking about right now cuz
you know you could be talking about yeah
cuz I have my own agenda I might be
talking about Delta or whatever right
yeah but if we were like I always wanted
to be a pirate and I'm like well maybe
he that he feels all didn't get to be a
pirate yeah yeah we gotta figure out the
I'm on I'm on the topic for tonight well
submit it by fortnight right some anyway
I need I need to stop playing for at
night see this is the issue here all of
us need to play because this is gonna
help us connect with our fan base what
was the last like game you played was
the last game anyone played Grand Theft
Auto all [ __ ] jackbox TV what's not
real oh that's true last game I played
was a Street Fighter 2
Donkey Kong baby at the arcade on Super
Nintendo and Genesis put in a quarter
you guys play cat Mario kidding I'm a
1990 dude parents are paying for 20 per
hour fortnight coaches to train their
kids in the video game oh you know how
how do you be a fortnight cook you would
plan to get four three money sports as
though
now gaming is a huge thing it's like the
[ __ ] MBA no it's like it's like
football
we've seen the events were they ran out
of [ __ ] arena yeah it's like the
Staples Center is it's like a LAN party
right they even get contracts and [ __ ]
like actually like athletes like I love
the athlete eSports is a real thing like
five on five or something right and it's
like these twelve year old Chinese kids
and it they're all Chinese they're
pretty Asian they either Chinese or they
look Chinese dude I was I used to be in
a billet Korean are you in the league I
used to be the clan I doesn't know I
can't make it cool call it no no we're
weirdos we called the Geo you mean all
Wow no no [ __ ] no and you know Wow
I put every quest [ __ ] don't know I
played a game why did why ever was but I
played a game called team fortress
classic which was like it was like a it
was like a shooting game where you you
try to capture the flag and so I was but
I was in a clan and we were [ __ ]
really [ __ ] good were you getting
paid
no [ __ ] no the last time I played like
that was Counter Strike do asking
parents right no the when I was in but
that's like the beginning of this [ __ ]
so that's how old I am
Counter Strike yeah but have you guys
heard everybody knows for at night I
hear about it I don't know anything
about it but I know it's popping yeah it
makes me want to play it you know why
I'm afraid to play games cuz last time I
played GTA no no no no there's the game
that everybody Brandi what's that game
what's that game we play I'm sorry it's
own professional Brandon what's that
game where we play [ __ ] medieval
legends is that the game that we that we
got really into that was really popular
League of Legends League of Legends each
okay which ones that one I've heard of
that imagine this all right so it's like
playing a pickup game of basketball but
it's not basketball you have your team
it's like five on five and then you have
to come in and it's like capture the
flag but then you know you got your
characters and [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
battle it out and you upgrade your
characters I play that you shoot again
no no it's like it's like I don't know
what do you call it it's like Rome no
it's not roleplay it's not shooter game
does no no you look at your character
it's a little character like this okay
you see them a third person third person
no no Jeff just said Sims like in the
clothes we cousinship sound like senior
citizens trying to make sense of the
internet right now I love
you talk about memes and [ __ ] when I
played that game 48 hours straight when
I [ __ ] got introduced to it no break
just to eat with the TV screen and when
you want to look for stuff you just
write in what you're looking for but you
have to put www in front of it yeah
Internet is [ __ ] I get hooked one day
when GTA the last one came out I was
like check this out guys
you won't see me for a week comes out
you predicted your own magic trick hey
guys watch this [ __ ] you won't see me
for a week and then like of course you
don't see you for a week and you're like
I told you okay loser
man I had to excuse myself like hey rain
you know I'm a prepare you you're not
gonna have somebody here for a whole
entire week I'm gonna be gone playing
this game that's how important it was
GTA is the only brand I agree
GT is my [ __ ] video clip dad who hired
coach for his kid I would too could
their [ __ ] making bang up their game
so bad Paul has enlisted the help of a
virtual tutor I think our time with them
super limited especially with work and I
was kind of watching them play and I
thought like I should check this out
he's paying upwards of $25 a pop to help
all three of them improve their play
they're california-based coach Chris
Nara says he has more than 30 clients
and growing that's a good really help
people achieve their dreams
I say coaching is know some shittin some
wonder if this is yet another example of
parents going over the top to make their
kids winners but Paul says it's all
about bonding with his sons this is one
of many things that we do together when
they have an interest in something it
definitely it definitely makes things
easier you know what the funny thing is
though those cute little 10 year olds
are the same ones telling you to go get
ass [ __ ] yeah you hear the little
voices like like
hey you [ __ ] shut up dude we
should be the trash talk coach my don't
say go we get ass [ __ ] my gonna say
who's getting asked what is that you're
their dad is it their mom I guess their
sister that's a five that's what pans
them more these kids are seven and nine
years old they're right now they're just
saying that you're such a loser I'll own
you then in just two more years you're
gonna start saying the AGG oh yeah yeah
yeah they're gonna say every single
racial epithet and invent new ones yeah
that's what's great about eight nine ten
year olds is that they have the minds
create brand new epithets that we
haven't heard you and I'm excited for
that
yeah yes a lot of people heard this
story and they were just like outraged
or just why god what why would people
pay what would these parents pay coaches
to help them that's like a private swim
coach yeah private [ __ ] basketball
coach what's the difference perspective
on this story here to worry it's like
yeah it's a hobby that they can get
better at and in like plus there's this
is an actual career now where people are
getting paid like they'll probably have
the same chances of making it like in a
professional basketball yeah how about
this they have more of a chance of
making it than a [ __ ] piano teacher
has it teaches some kid to be a concert
pianist true give me a Freeman back the
knife for that I know they don't cuz her
[ __ ] because it doesn't look fun
let's be honest that's what it looks
like that they don't want me to do
that's right that's all its ever about
right if it looks fun it's like it's
like YouTube right what's the story
whenever you're interviewed for a
newspaper or for TV but I but I like you
guys have been here right but I'm
talking about I don't I can't even
imagine that we're not saying but with
the you know with the YouTube people who
get interviewed what's the story I don't
think the story is the same thing every
time it's how much money do you guys
make or no the question is you guys
really make money on this doing this
right yes it looks fun that's like one
of the things I hear all the time
speaking to like new people that go what
do you do oh I just do videos on YouTube
and they're like ah wow you make money
doing that that's it or sometimes it's
condescending like oh that's a full-time
thing it's all
responses some like it is if your work
sucks
I knew be condescending back that's
great oh is that what I did I love that
no I might think is I love like you go
into any Hollywood Reporter article it's
like it's like YouTube or XYZ just signs
a Nickelodeon deal and then you go
around and the bottom thing and say [ __ ]
these people [ __ ] their lives like [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] because they're just
jealous because it looks fun and that's
what this is it just looks fun in people
like how dare you get trained and how
dare you pay money for how do you raise
kids duh how did it be good at fun right
exactly
that's exactly right I just love the
idea that this guy this coach guy he
pulls the data side and he's like listen
he's like Dustin's not [ __ ] cutting
it he's not know isn't care cuz he want
to wait fortnight or not does he want to
use the grappling hook and [ __ ] win
again like he's not building his forts
right like listen listen like he's
really I don't know what he's been doing
he's been watching the news or something
has been doing homework taking time away
from the dad coach like for soccer and
all that [ __ ] but they're going hard
[ __ ] core for for connecting that's
see that's our next movie like fighting
with the ref and all that [ __ ]
that would be dope dude oh you know
there's actually a lot of [ __ ] work
that goes into this stuff that people
just don't understand like kids are
getting carpal tunnel I like 16 and [ __ ]
just you're not getting carpal tunnel
from that yeah you know what almost all
six are young males have carpal tunnel
porn is the number one in the world
number one most searched [ __ ] in the
world right now and the internet the
database the [ __ ] storage space
that's used it's like 60% porn or some
outrageous amount do you know how many
clinics are gonna be of guys like holder
like they just don't I can't [ __ ]
even move my [ __ ] hands like I got so
much I'm like guys are going to suck
their own dick when they're 60 because
they can't jerk off anymore because the
users are on their hands like in your
example there's no women around
listen must be honest
[Laughter]
[Music]